[Music]
daddy brock we've been waiting in the
darkness for you
on october 1st
the universe
is expanding it's something way bigger
than you and me
i'm done with this guy
why me
we all have secrets you know what
secrets wanted they went out
[Music]
every decision has consequences eddie
i'd like you to meet the carnage
venom
lady here
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys
i am a predator
i need to be free you have got to get
control of your aggression
we will get hauled off into area 51.
you live in my body you live by my walls
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it so i can fix it
again
you are a loser
eddie brock i want to give you my
story people love serial killers
cletus why me
that's mine
it's yours and what's yours
is mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not it
all i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
i'm not a crazy man
i promise oh yeah
betty
you feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be us hey i'm
happy for you
god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing
some serious couples counseling
[Music]
you